hey guys it's Jonah here so when you're
all tucked in ready for bedtime I want
you to work your abs and hips with these
five sexy moves this fun and sexy
exercises will strengthen your car and
it will give you a tighten lower abs and
also hips it only takes five minutes 45
seconds of workout with 15 seconds rest
interval for each exercise so here are
the workouts
so I'm going to set my timer and
remember throughout the whole workout
remember to engage your core and keep
your core tight for maximum result
let's start on outside with single leg
raise so keep your left leg vendor right
leg pointer okay and all I want you to
do is support arms bring your legs in
and kick it back up so in up
so all these what we're aiming for is
sexy
move there you go point and kick it up
good point in kicker bring it in flirt
and up good really kick and work your
hips and also the side of your ass kick
good job keep going good now just switch
over and change side up bring it in
kick good in and up very nice kick and
point the toes nice long legs point the
toes break your hips and your ass and
just gently support your upper body few
more good job and now 15 seconds rest
now get onto your back get onto your
elbow and what we want to do is come big
flirt okay so bring both legs up and
let's start with your right leg
blurt it and bring it in okay so right
leg so go left leg good in and out to
really engage your core you want to keep
your legs straight and keep them pointed
throughout and just lower them slightly
and keep your abs engaged
flag it swing swing it in draw a circle
and draw a circle good job nice keep
going and now let's do double leg swing
one side keep going very nice so just to
put upper body and work your hips a
little ass the other way nice right
point the toes keep going few more whew
should start to feel your apps in the
same position what we want to do next is
point a link cycle so just like bicycle
crunches we want to Felix just like
riding a bike
okay so I gave printer licks keep it
small and get your little ass
keep your legs pointed and now let's go
big and extend your legs okay to really
feel your abs you gotta extend your legs
push it and pedal hard good so not small
but really extend your legs and keep
them long and engage your lower abs good
job now let's go for small pointed bring
it out high high good big circle good
cycle let's pedal hard point the legs
keep them long good all the way down and
all the way up nice view more good job
now just lie flat on your back okay
extend your arms by your side and what
we want to do is signal leg circle okay
whoo take a breather bring both legs up
okay
let's start with our left leg circle and
right leg so alternate left right again
keep your toes pointed and engage yellow
apps up into up good serve the one side
circle and bring them up to meet good
job keep going big circle big circle
draw a big circle one side and the other
side you should really feel a little
apps engaged and burning and at the same
time this huge circle will be working on
your hips keep going nice good more one
more and just rest it out still with
your arms extended we want to do cross
leg spin
okay sexy moves ladies sexy moves okay
whoa find a workout let's do it
so bring cross split and bring it back
up
cross spit open up meet cross split up
get cross split up nice keep going
split up cross split and up so hips
Bookman lower ass to bring your legs
together up cross slip and up nice
well can you feel as burning and you
should be sweating slightly as a up nice
cross ah keep going cross and up I'm
feeling sexy and I'm feeling sweating
one more cross up and meet good job well
done
that was five sexy acts and hips moves
for you to do before your bed time at
the end of this workout if you're
feeling sexy then repeat the entire
routine two to three more times do this
workout two to three times weekly on
alternate days for best result and just
remember that we cannot spot reduce fat
in order to get a flat belly it is a
combination of a regular cardio strength
training core workout and eating a
well-balanced diet if you stay
consistent in four to six weeks trust me
you will see and feel the difference all
the best for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
you